[Applaudissements]
bonsoir vous trouvez ça normal vous qu'à
six ans subitement on veut rentrer ou cp
on vous annonce qu'à partir de
maintenant vous allez rester à six
heures par jour sur une chaise à
apprendre par coeur tout ce qu'un adulte
va vous raconter jusque là cité
tranquille
franchement on apprenait en s'amusant en
explorant en écoutant les adultes a
vraiment dans un processus très simple
vont s'adapter au monde qui nous entoure
est et finalement sans effort conséquent
pour apprendre et là on bascule dans un
autre monde à celui où on va être assis
et apprendre vraiment de façon passive
enregistré travailler tout seul de façon
très individuelle et là où ça devient
vraiment être en jambes c'est que quand
on est adulte de nouveau dans le monde
du travail
on va nous demander au fil de l'eau de
nous adapter à notre nouveau métier de
nous adapter aux évolutions qui arrive
et c'est de plus en plus vrai avec les
évolutions technologiques qui font que
les métiers évoluent massivement et
qu'on va changer de carrière plusieurs
fois dans notre vie
les enfants qui rentrent à l'école
aujourd'hui pour 65% d'entre eux au
moins feront un métier qui n'existe pas
encore et ça ça change les paradigmes et
la façon dont il faut enseigner aux
jeunes alors de plus en plus du fait de
ces évolutions nombreuses on parle des
softs qu'ils a alors je ne sais pas si
vous avez entendu parler d sauf qu'ils
aient des hearts kinza mais globalement
les ars kinza c'est ce que vous savez ce
sont vos compétences à les savoir faire
c'est ce qu'on vous apprend à l'école ce
qui est validée par un diplôme
ça peut être parler une langue étrangère
apprendre à programmer la comptabilité
les softs qu'ils se rencontrent ce sont
les savoir-être
donc ça va être comment je me comporte
avec les autres et quand on parle des
compétences du 21e siècle on parle
énormément des softs qu'ils qui vont
être l'esprit critique la capacité de
travail en équipe la créativité la
capacité à communiquer
et si auparavant ce qui était surtout
valoriser c'était les hearts qu'ils ce
que vous validiez par votre diplôme de
plus en plus ce sont les softs qui sont
valorisés et à 77%
les employeurs déclarent que les softs
qu'ils sont aussi voire plus important
que les hearts qu'ils à est forcément
force est de constater que pour 92% des
salariés
il considère que la transformation
digitale va bouleverser leur métier et
ce de façon de plus en plus forte
or justement ces bouleversements ce sont
les uns ce qu'ils qui comme vous le
voyez bien évolué au fil du temps à
l'évidence ça il va falloir modifier la
façon dont on enseigne aux jeunes à
l'école je m'appelle sharon se faire
j'ai 47 ans et j'ai créé start up for
kids en 2014 à notre ambition avec start
up for kids c'est de préparer les jeunes
au monde de demain à travers des
ateliers des sessions de créativité la
découverte de nouvelles façons
d'apprendre mais aussi des hackaton qui
sont des journées de créativité pendant
lesquelles on invite les jeunes à
inventer le monde de demain donc dû ans
et c'est un carton vraiment les enfants
sont plongés à embarquer dans cette
créativité ou par équipe
on les invite à créer des projets pour
rendre le futur meilleur donc pardon
donc avant d'avoir monté certains partis
j'ai travaillé pendant une vingtaine
d'années dans la technologie
donc j'ai monté plusieurs entreprises et
en 2000 en autour de 40 ans j'ai créé
mon premier projet si un petit box c'est
un petit box
le concept c'est de permettre aux
enfants de découvrir la science de façon
ludique
ça a été mon premier projet entrepôts
ryan qui a été un véritable succès
d'estimé et donc à travers six ans petit
box a vraiment j'ai perdu ça m'a permis
de beaucoup apprendre et c'est là que
j'ai créé la première édition starter
for kids qui était au début un projet de
communication pour valoriser son petit
box et en fait on peut le dire start up
for kids c'était en pivot de sion petit
box en fait donc
alors il faut le savoir dans le monde
des start-up un pivot c'est vraiment la
capacité de pouvoir rebondir et lancer
un nouveau projet comme on le dit
souvent faire un premier projet et
échouer finalement c'est comme ça dans
la nba
donc on apprend toujours tout au long de
ces expériences alors quand j'ai monté
que ce soit son petit box aux start up
for kids le bal en jambes disait bip
quand même très bizarre à travailler
dans le marketing dans la tête tu as eu
des bouleaux hyper d'intéressant
pourquoi tu t'en met à monter des
projets qui sont super compliqué qui
connaît rien du tout franchement t'as
jamais fait de logistique de production
dans quoi tu t'embarques et pareil pour
start up for kids c'est complexe et moi
je comprenais pas trop parce que
franchement ça n'a pas l'air d'être la
mer à boire de monter ces projets et
puis c'était plutôt rigolo de faire des
choses nouvelles et du coup j'ai dû
commencer à réfléchir
mais pourquoi moi ça me paraît assez
logique finalement de me lancer dans ces
projets alors que ça a l'air super
compliqué pour la plupart des gens qui
m'entourent et j'ai fait un petit
flashback dans mon histoire et c'est
vrai que quand j'étais étudiante envers
18 entre 18 et 21 ans
évitez président d'une association
militante et en tant que présidente de
cette association j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir monter des projets vraiment
ambitieux et du coup à travers ses
projets ça c'était pour à travers à
travers ses projets j'ai eu la chance
d'envoyer un convoi humanitaire à
sarajevo en pleine guerre en ex
yougoslavie ou monter une convention de
400 étudiants pendant trois jours avec
une équipe de 3 personnes ce qui peut
paraître un peu ridicule mais finalement
l'avantagé c'est que quand on a 18 ans
en fait on croit que tout est possible
donc on y va on est persuadé qu on est
vachement plus malin que les adultes et
qu'on va pouvoir se débrouiller tout
seul et ça c'est vrai que avoir
expérimenté ce learning by doing à
l'époque où finalement bas j'avais peur
de rien et les risques étaient limitées
et je vais pas vous mentir on a fait des
bonnes grosses bêtises ça vous donne une
force et vous savez que vous avez la
capacité de réaliser
des projets extrêmement ambitieux avec
les moyens que vous avez est aujourd'hui
notre société
les jeunes ont encore plus de défis que
nous avions eu les défis majeurs c'est
évidemment les bouleversements
climatiques et évidemment la technologie
qui fait évoluer les choses très très
vite et souvent les adultes eux mêmes
sont un peu désemparés et moins
régulièrement un certain fort qu'ils
j'entends des parents qui me disent mais
mon enfant je lui mets une tablette dans
la main et là ils se débrouillent tout
seuls franchement j'ai pas besoin de
l'accompagner il est beaucoup plus doués
que moi je dis pas oui mais tu sais toi
ton était petit on a bien vu dans les
mains tu te tourner les pages
et tu sais quoi tu es toujours pas aulas
donc donc votre enfant c'est pareil il
s'est posté des photos sur instagram
mais c'est pas ou kehrberg vous faites
pas d'illusions en tout cas s'il ya
certainement une chose que que le
numérique a transformé et justement
cette expression de digital natives à
elle est très troublante parce que c'est
ça qui fait que en fait les parents les
enseignants les adultes se disent ok nos
enfants ils sont nés avec le numérique
donc ils savent se débrouiller en fait
ok ils sont nés en même temps mais et
alors c'est pas ça qui par un transfert
mafiques fait qu'ils sauront se
débrouiller
donc il faut quand même continuer à les
accompagner même si nous on n'a pas
forcément les clés parce que c'est vrai
nous ne sommes pas nés à l'ère du
digital
on est moins équipés que pour pour se
débrouiller avec la tête mais on a quand
même cette mission d'être là avec eux et
d accompagner est un point essentiel
dans le digital c'est l'attention
en gros pour qu'un enfant ou un ado ou
un adulte même après il faut qu'il
réussisse a focalisé son attention si on
fait un retour en arrière quand l'école
a été rendue obligatoire
c'était il ya un petit moment déjà en
gros la perspective pour un gamin est
bon si je n'allais pas à l'école
j'allais à la mine à l'usiné au chant
avec mes parents forcément c'était pas
fan j'étais mieux sur les sur les bancs
de l'école à apprendre
aujourd'hui je vais pas à l'école non
c'est pas qu'il ya s'est fait l'écho
récemment mais vous faites du beam
switching sur netflix vous essayez
d'être le dernier survivant dans
fortnight et va tout de suite c'est plus
rigolo qu'aller à l'école et donc
l'école elle un défi majeur
outre à l'époque elle fabriquait des
personnes assez similaire les unes aux
autres pour travailler à la [ __ ]
jingwei soldats aujourd'hui il faut
qu'elle réussisse à engager les jeunes à
les intéresser et surtout à fabriquer
des jeunes qui vont réussir à penser par
eux-mêmes et à être créatifs donc le
défi est de taille
donc comment je capte cette attention
pour nous la raison première est ce
qu'il va marquer l'attention des enfants
c'est vraiment de les engager a donc il
va falloir lutter pour cette attention
et engager les enfants donc franklin
disais tu me dis j'oublie tu mancelle je
me souviens tu n'implique j'apprends
donc le nerf de la guerre c'est vraiment
d'impliquer les enfants de les faire
travailler en projet en collaboratif sur
des sujets qui les intéressent ou c'est
ce qu'on essaye de faire à travers en
particulier des hackaton ou à leur
montre qu'en fait ils ont énormément de
capacité et que grâce à eux
finalement ils vont apporter leur pierre
à l'édifice et ils vont changer le monde
a donc clairement il faut réussir à
embarquer cette jeunesse ça et moi je
vous demande pas de me croire sur parole
sur le fait que les engagés ça marche je
vais inviter eva nicolas flavie et
oriane à veut dire vous raconter
bonjour je m'appelle et weill et 10 ans
vieux vieilles avec mes parents
architectes nicholas l'écossé deux mois
et pablo autre grand frère qui
participent à un marathon et plusieurs
ateliers surtout de construction bonjour
thomas nicholas et j'ai 11 ans depuis
que je suis tout petit j'adore faire des
projets avec ma soeur eva ce projet on
peut les réaliser autant la maison qu'à
l'école j'ai fait un carton et plusieurs
ateliers d'informatique de construction
pascal est très sympa car elle applique
une méthode éducatif basé sur la
nouvelle donne
ce que j'aime c'est apprendre en faisant
gm lire sur différents sujets et pouvoir
les expérimentés moi-même pour avoir mon
30 à lille nous avons toujours plein
d'idées dans nos têtes nous avons besoin
de les réaliser
parfois c'est nicholas kelly des raisons
bassement qui démarrent les projets on
expérimente avec la maquette on rajoute
des choses on les change et après on
commence une autre
nous avons participé tous les deux à
plusieurs ateliers et un marathon où
nous étions par hasard dans la même
équipe
nous avons adoré avoir un diplôme mais
surtout remporté la première place
l'expérience de création des projets a
été génial surtout les protections
intervenants il ateliers créatifs
le fait qu'ils aient des groupes et par
conséquent pour sa peau
moi j'adorais ça la maquette du projet
j'aimerais que lui dès que nous avons
créé puissent être réalisés pour devrait
un jour je suis sûr que ce type
d'expérience nous ont servi à compenser
ce que nous pouvons faire pour le futur
est encore temps didier en tête à
réaliser moi je
depuis j'ai commencé à parler tous les
projets partout chine est ce que les
paroles n'apprécie pas forcément ou
collecter de maccarone de la ville du
coup ils disent que ma chambre quand ça
ressemble à un vrai dépotoir
mais bon c'est du classique de la vie à
l'inventaire bonjour je m'appelle
flamini et j'ai douze ans j'ai fait 4 à
caton dans des équipes de michael il
s'agit en groupe de quatre ou cinq
enfants qui ne se connaissent pas au
départ de réfléchir ensemble pour créer
une maquette autour de la solution
qu'ils imaginent pour demain par exemple
la ville de demain l'école de demain ou
encore les transports de demain
j'ai beaucoup appris en faisant ces
hackaton j'ai pu m'améliorer dans le
travail collaboratif
par exemple comment réfléchir ensemble
pour développer les idées de chacun et
développer une idée nouvelle à partir
des idées des chaque personne j'ai pu
m'améliorer a aussi sur l'exercice du
pitch comme par exemple sur la gestion
du temps pour faire passer les idées
principales
j'ai trouvé très amusant de réfléchir
sur une thématique de notre quotidien et
à partir de là inventer une solution
inventer demain
le fait de réaliser une maquette aident
les autres à comprendre un peu plus
l'idée et nous mais aussi dans un monde
créatif
j'ai trouvé très intéressant de pouvoir
découvrir les maquettes des autres pour
voir comment ils ont interprété le même
sujet apprend dans faisant c'est génial
bonsoir à tous je m'appelle oriane j'ai
17 ans et il ya quelques semaines j'ai
eu l'occasion de participer 1 à caton
c'est-à-dire un événement au cours
duquel des développeurs se regroupent et
concrétise divers projets de
programmation alors dit comme ça c'est
vrai que ça peut paraître barbant voire
inaccessible mais je peux vous promettre
que j'ai vécu une aventure incroyable
avec trois amis arbres en l'espace de
seulement cinq jours il a fallu qu avec
mon équipe nous réfléchissions à une
idée futuriste qui révolutionne
complètement une de nos actuels
industries créatives et en l'occurrence
de nous avions choisi les musées après
la réfection d'un sûr il a fallu que
nous bâtissions le prototype de notre
projet sous la forme d'une maquette n'a
pas été de tout repos et à vrai dire
j'étais loin de me douter que nous
réussirions à voir l'aboutissement de
notre projet enfin le dernier jour avant
pitcher notre projet devant jury
vraiment très qualifiés groupe après
groupe et contre toute attente mon
équipe et moi avoue remporté le premier
prix pour notre application museum for
research and education qui grâce à la
technologie d
des hologrammes transformerait un lieu
fixe tels qu'une salle de classe où
cette salle de spectacles en n'importe
quel musée recensés dans le monde au
cours de cette semaine
au cours de cette semaine j'ai rencontré
des personnes extrêmement créative et
super sympathique j'ai fait quoi j'ai
assisté à des interventions de
professionnels venant de divers horizons
mais aussi de coach en prise de parole
est en confiance en soi ce qui m'a
beaucoup aidé personnellement ça a
vraiment été j'ai vraiment vécu ça
comment un grand bol d'air frais parce
que si j'ai pas l'habitude d'en prendre
de cette façon là c'est agir en
m'amusant autant et en mettant ainsi à
profit mon imagination
et puis c'est surtout cette victoire
inattendue qui a clôturé cette semaine
et du chante de la meilleure des façons
maintenant on est on est hyper cf parce
que quand on a des groupes d'enfants et
qui pèse quelques jours quelques heures
quelques semaines avec nous voilà on les
voit grandir progresser et surtout non
ce sens dans notre responsabilité parce
que si nous on veut une jeunesse qui
puisse faire avancer le monde difficile
dans lequel ils vivent qu'ils puissent
être les acteurs de notre avenir à nous
aussi en tant qu'adulte on a le devoir
de s'engager de faire partie de la
solution comme ils l'exigent à juste
titre à merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]